una buena relación sin precedentes a
mitad de mandato el presidente de
gobierno español pedro sánchez anunció
siete cambios en el ejecutivo con un
claro objetivo la recuperación económica
tras la pandemia crisis que ha marcado
el gobierno actual desde su formación en
el medio de 2020 el nuevo gobierno
supone en primer lugar una renovación
generacional la edad media del anterior
ejecutivo era de 55 años el de nuevo
gobierno será de 50 años el nuevo
gobierno va a reforzar aún más la
presencia de mujeres al frente de los
ministerios
la ingeniera diana morant ocupará el
puesto de ministra de ciencia e
innovación la abogada isabel rodríguez
será la encargada del ministerio de
política territorial y portavoz del
gobierno
la también jurista raquel sánchez
desempeñará el cargo de ministra de
transportes sustituye así a josé luís
ábalos uno de los nombres de peso que
abandonó en el ejecutivo como la hasta
ahora vicepresidenta primera carmen
calvo responsable de la exhumación de
francos y el proyecto de ley de memoria
democrática calvo será relevada por
félix bolaños hombre de máxima confianza
de sánchez también hay reemplazo en el
ministerio exteriores que lo lidera el
diplomático josé manuel álvarez
de qué lado sientes tensiones con
marruecos desprestigiar an a la ministra
gonzález la ya la cartera educativa será
ocupada por pilar alegría una de las
figuras con mayor proyección en el
partido socialista en el ministerio de
justicia en trap hilario ex presidenta
del senado con largo recorrido contra la
violencia de género fruto de la
estructuración la ministra de economía
nadie a calviño pasa de segunda primera
vicepresidenta una figura clave para
cumplir con el objetivo de salir de la
crisis económica en sintonía con
bruselas